KRUMP FOR OUR
INTRODUCTIONS.
>> WELCOME TO NBA ALL STAR 2022.
PLEASE WELCOME CLEVELAND'S OWN
MACHINE GUN KELLY!
>> CLEVELAND!
GET OUT YOUR SEATS.
EVERYBODY GET OUT YOUR SEATS
RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE BRINGING THE ENERGY THIS
YEAR.
WHERE'S THE CAMERA AT?
I WANT TO WELCOME TO THE WORLD
TO OUR CITY, CLEVELAND, OHIO,
FOR THE 2022 NBA ALL-STAR GAME!
MAKE SOME NOISE OUT THERE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> I WANT TO ENJOY THIS MOMENT.
WE ONLY GET ONE OF THESE IN OUR
TOWN LIKE EVERY 20 OR 25 YEARS.
THAT MEANS NEXT TIME I MIGHT
HAVE SOME GRAY HAIR, WHICH IS
KIND OF DEPRESSING.
I'M SUPPOSED TO ACTUALLY LIST
OFF A GROUP OF PEOPLE,
CELEBRITIES WHO MADE IT FROM
CLEVELAND BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
DO THAT.
I WANT TO SHOUT OUT ALL THE HARD
WORKERS OF THIS TOWN WHO KEEP
THE HEARTS PUMPING AND SHOUT OUT
ALL THE FANS WHO FILL UP THE
STANDS WHETHER THEY'RE WINNING
OR LOSING AND SUPPORT THE
ARTISTS.
MAKE SOME NOISE FOR YOURSELVES,
CLEVELAND.
WE GOT THE 75th ANNIVERSARY TEAM
IN THE HOUSE TONIGHT AND OF
COURSE THE REASON WHY WE'RE ALL
HERE, WE HAVE THE BEST
BASKETBALL PLAYERS IN THE WORLD
HERE TO PLAY ON OUR COURT FOR
THE NBA ALL-STAR GAME.
MAKE SOME NOISE FOR THEM.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> ALL RIGHT, LOOK, I'M NOT A
GREAT BASKETBALL -- OKAY, I'M
NOT EVEN A GOOD BASKETBALL
PLAYER, BUT I DID STEAL ALL THE
AFFINITY STONES, SO LeBRON, IF
YOU NEED SOMETHING, I CAN
PROBABLY SINK SOMETHING FROM
HALFCOURT.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO STEP OUT.
DEEJAY, BE NICE.
>> CLEVELAND, MAKE SOME NOISE!
>> I GO BY THE NAME OF D-NICE
AND I'M SO HYPED TO BE HERE.
WE HAVE TWO INCREDIBLE TEAMS
GETTING READY TO HEAD IT UP.
IT'S TIME TO GET THIS PARTY
STARTED.
ARE YOU READY TO ROCK WITH ME
RIGHT NOW?
I SAID ARE YOU READY TO ROCK
WITH ME RIGHT NOW, CLEVELAND?
IT'S ONLY RIGHT I GIVE YOU SOME
OHIO FLAVOR FOR THESE OHIO
PLAYERS.
I GOT A LEGEND FROM THE LONE
STAR STATE TO HELP ME OUT.
DIRK, TELL THEM WHAT'S UP.
>> IF SPEED AND STRENGTH IS YOUR
THING, THEN THIS IS YOUR TEAM.
THESE GUYS CAN CREATE OFF THE
DRIBBLE, THEY CAN SCORE IN THE
POST AND, TRUST ME, THEY CAN
FLY.
THIS IS TEAM DURANT.
>> THE HEAD COACH FOR TEAM
DURANT IS MAKING HIS SECOND
ALL-STAR APPEARANCE.
JUST NAMED ONE OF THE TOP 15 NBA
COACHES OF ALL TIME.
FROM THE MIAMI HEAT, ERIK
SPOELSTRA!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
INJURED AND UNABLE TO ATTEND IS
THE CAPTAIN OF TEAM DURANT,
12-TIME ALL-STAR KEVIN DURANT!
AND NOW FOR YOUR TEAM DURANT
RESERVES, UNABLE TO COMPETE DUE
TO INJURY, HE'S A FOUR-TIME
ALL-STAR, A THREE-TIME NBA
CHAMPION, FROM THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS, DRAYMOND GREEN!
MAKING HIS ALL-STAR GAME DEBUT
AND THE LEAGUE'S REIGNING ROOKIE
OF THE YEAR, FROM THE CHARLOTTE
HORNETS, LAMELO BALL!
AND MAKING HIS FIRST APPEARANCE,
ONE OF THE MOST VERSATILE
PLAYERS IN THE GAME REPRESENTING
THE SAN ANTONIO SPURS, DEJOUNTE
MURRAY!
HE'S A TWO-TIME SLAM DUNK
CHAMPION AND A TWO-TIME
ALL-STAR, FROM THE CHICAGO
BULLS, ZACH LaVINE!
A THREE-TIME ALL-STAR AND
THREE-TIME DEFENSIVE PLAYER
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR, FROM THE
UTAH JAZZ, RUDY GOBERT!
MAKING HIS THIRD ALL-STAR
APPEARANCE FROM THE 2021 NBA
CHAMPION MILWAUKEE BUCKS, KHRIS
MIDDLETON!
ANOTHER THREE-TIME ALL-STAR FROM
THE WESTERN CONFERENCE LEADING
PHOENIX SUNS, DEVIN BOOKER!
NAMED ROOKIE OF THE YEAR IN 2016
AND A THREE-TIME ALL-STAR FROM
THE MINNESOTA TIMBERWOLVES,
KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS!
AND NOW THE STARTERS FOR TEAM
DURANT.
A THREE-TIME ALL-STAR FROM THE
BOSTON CELTICS NOW MAKING HIS
SECOND CONSECUTIVE START, JAYSON
TATUM!
HE WAS THE NUMBER ONE PICK IN
THE 2014 NBA DRAFT AND THE
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR IN 2015,
MAKING HIS ALL-STAR GAME DEBUT
FROM THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS,
ANDREW WIGGINS!
HE'S RANKED IN TOP FIVE IN BOTH
SCORING AND ASSISTS THIS SEASON,
A TWO-TIME ALL-STAR FROM THE
ATLANTA HAWKS MAKING HIS SECOND
START, TREY YOUNG!
THE 2020 KIA NBA ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR AND ONE OF THE LEAGUE'S
MOST ELECTRIFYING PLAYERS,
APPEARED IN HIS FIRST ALL-STAR
GAME FROM THE MEMPHIS GRIZZLIES,
JA MORAN!
HE DOMINATES, FROM THE
PHILADELPHIA 76ERS, JOEL EMBIID!
LET'S HEAR IT ONE MORE TIME FOR
TEAM DU